en los últimos vídeos demostré cómo
tomar una función digamos efe que
depende de dos variables x verdad dos
variables de entrada y tomamos una
función para poder hallar el plano
tangente a la gráfica de esta función en
un punto dado verdad y la forma en la
que pensamos esto es considerando un
punto arbitrario x0 y espero que se
encuentre en el espacio de entradas y
ahora tenemos que evaluar la función en
este punto para saber cuál es la altura
a la que nos encontramos sobre la
gráfica y el punto era tratar de
construir una función l que depende de
quién eran la función original verdad
que también tuviera dos variables de
entrada verdad y esta función
esencialmente lo que quiere es tratar de
de ser aquella que su gráfica sea el
plano tangente a la gráfica en el punto
que nos interesa por hadas ese era el
objetivo ya todo este método también se
le conoce de la siguiente forma se le
conoce como línea lización
finalización local y quizás vale la pena
decir que significa cada una de estas
cosas por ejemplo la palabra local
significa que en realidad nos estamos
fijando en los alrededores de un punto
de entrada específico que aquí hemos
denotado como x0 10 0 y por otro lado la
palabra línea lización verdad en
realidad lo que nos está diciendo es que
estamos aproximando la función con otra
función que es lineal y es mucho más
simple y aunque en realidad hemos estado
hablando de planos tangentes en realidad
esto es una muy buena forma de aproximar
una función que podría ser muy
complicada en principio con digamos una
que sea mucho más fácil de entender
ahora bien el objetivo de este vídeo
será escribir la línea lización en forma
vectorial por supuesto que esta forma es
mucho más compacta y más general así que
recordemos cómo calculamos nuestra
función l
efe
ok entonces esta función lf en realidad
la calcula vamos tomando la derivada
parcial de f con respecto de xy
evaluamos en el punto que nos interesa x
0 10/0 y luego multiplicamos por la
variable x menos la coordenada x 0 de
nuestro punto que conocemos
luego sumamos la derivada parcial de f
con respecto de y evaluábamos también en
el punto x 0 10/0 y multiplicamos por ye
menos la segunda coordenada del punto
que conocemos que es 10 0 muy bien
entonces esto es digamos la parte que es
lineal de nuestra función y la razón por
la cual ponemos estos dos factores x
menos x 0 menos de 0 es porque a la hora
de evaluarlos en el punto x 0 y es cero
estos dos términos se cancelan verdad
entonces si estos dos se cancelan lo
único que necesitamos agregar es
efe evaluada en x0 de 0 entonces cuando
evaluamos todo esto en x 0 y es cero
estos términos se cancelan y simplemente
nos queda el valor de la función en el
punto que nos interesaba lo cual nos
dice que estas dos funciones
efe y lf coinciden en ese punto ahora
aquí es buen momento para decir a qué
nos referimos con que la función sea
lineal y en realidad tiene una
formulación muy precisa especialmente
cuando estamos en un curso de álgebra
lineal y en realidad esto que tenemos
aquí no es una función lineal en un
estricto sentido verdad digamos en el
sentido técnico pero la gente llama a
esta a esta función que es lineal porque
el término x que por ejemplo se
encuentra aquí el término x no tiene
nada de especial no tiene ningún
exponente no tiene cosas elegantes como
el seno de x no hay exponentes en fin
sólo está siendo multiplicado por una
constante fija verdad lo mismo ocurre
para la variable
aunque hay una forma mucho más técnica
de describir qué es una función lineal
esto es lo que necesitamos ver para este
curso de cálculo de varias variables
ahora quizás veas esto de una forma más
complicada en su curso y esto es
utilizando vectores entonces vamos a ver
esta forma que se utiliza mucho en los
cursos de cálculo verdad y la forma en
la que lo ve uno es pensando ahora en
vectores verdad entonces nuestra
variable de entrada x coma hielo
pensamos como un único vector ya esto lo
vamos a escribir como un vector que en
muchos libros lo denotan como digamos
con letras en negritas y es muy
desafortunado verdad porque aquí estamos
usando ya la variable x y el vector nos
referimos como x pero la diferencia que
hay entre la coordenada y el vector es
que el vector está escrito con negritas
muy bien entonces este vector está
escrito con negritas muy bien
también podríamos entonces escribir a
nuestro punto x 0 0 verdad vamos a
ponerlo aquí arriba podríamos escribir
al punto x 0 10 0 también como un vector
en negrita es verdad entonces vamos a
poner este vector x0 muy bien entonces
esto nos da la ventaja de que si estamos
hablando de una función en más
dimensiones en realidad sólo pensamos
que tenemos más coordenadas ya sabes en
la en el vector de entradas o en este
punto fijo inicial verdad entonces ahora
vamos a tratar de escribir esta parte de
la función esta parte de la función con
en notación vectorial muy bien entonces
lo primero que tenemos que ver es que
esto se ve esencialmente como un
producto punto verdad aquí sería una
coordenada es serían las dos coordenadas
de un vector y las dos coordenadas de
otro vector pero si nos fijamos en estas
en estos dos factores son las derivadas
parciales así que vamos a poner esto así
la derivada parcial de f con respecto de
x evaluada en el punto x 0 y es cero y
también tendremos la derivada parcial de
f con respecto de y evaluada en el punto
x 0 10/0 esto sí sería digamos nuestro
primer vector y luego hacemos el
producto punto con otro vector que
esencialmente es él el que tiene
coordenadas x menos x0 aquí aquí no lo
ponemos con negritas porque si son
coordenadas son números y la segunda
coordenada sería menos de 0 muy bien
entonces esencialmente hacemos el
producto punto de estos dos vectores
pero podríamos escribirlo todavía de
forma más compacta porque si observamos
este es el vector que tiene las
derivadas parciales así que esto en
realidad es el gradiente de nuestra
función y esto va evaluado en el vector
verdad en el vector
con negritas x0 y hacemos el producto
punto con otro vector es el vector x
menos el vector x 0 y es cero y entonces
el vector x que era el que poníamos como
x en negritas menos el siguiente vector
que es el x0 verdad del vector x0 - el
vector x cero entonces esencialmente
todo esto es la parte lineal de nuestra
función l
efe verdad habíamos anotado como el f
esta es la parte lineal y en realidad la
anotación con vectores es muy
conveniente porque ahora el gradiente
podría tener a lo mejor muchas más
coordenadas verdad a lo mejor x tiene
más coordenadas y por lo tanto x0
también debería tener más componentes y
esto es lo que es el término lineal en
nuestra terminología de cálculo de
varias variables pues el producto punto
esencialmente nos dice que los
componentes de nuestro vector
x negrita es verdad serán simplemente
multiplicados por una constante ahora en
realidad si recordamos cómo es nuestra
función
lf sólo nos falta sumar este término que
es la función evaluada en el punto x 0 0
pero ya sabemos que el punto x 0 y es 0
lo podemos poner como este vector en
negrita es verdad y se lo sumamos a lo
que ya teníamos entonces esta es la
parte constante de nuestra función y a
mí me gusta ponerlo del lado izquierdo
porque como veremos más adelante después
podemos seguir agregando otros términos
que serán cuadráticas entonces este es
esto es por lo la razón por la cual me
gusta ponerlo del lado izquierdo y
notemos que el único lugar en donde se
encuentra la variable x verdad
la variable x que es el vector es este y
lo más importante es que una vez que has
hecho las cuentas en realidad obtenemos
una función f que es mucho más simple
que que a lo mejor quizás nos ayude a
escribir un programa que haga cuentas
más rápido o quizá
era una función que no conocíamos de
inicio porque a lo mejor si sabíamos
cuánto valía en un punto dado a lo mejor
sabíamos cuánto vale a su gradiente y
entonces de esta forma podemos aproximar
la función alrededor de ese punto y
nuevamente sé que esto parece muy
abstracto por si tratas de desenmarañar
todo esto y ver de dónde proviene espero
que todo esto cobre sentido y que notes
que es la función más simple posible que
tiene el mismo valor que f y que además
coinciden sus derivadas parciales verdad
son iguales que la función original y si
quieres ver más ejemplos de todo esto
digamos como para ver cómo aproximar
funciones
tengo un artículo de ello y creo que
sería muy bueno que sigas los ejemplos
con papel y lápiz en mano con esto dicho
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo